well
just wait a moment as
people
are joining I do apologize for tonight's delay we just completed the
Shema and readings with the celebrate mercy audience and we
just had to extend it a little bit longer but
inshallah this is the beginning of
our
nightly
gatherings in Ramadan and the
idea of this gathering is
is that it's a very brief reminder insha'Allah so we're not going to be together for
too long because the intention is that we spend a lot more time in personal worship
in any battle with Allah subhana WA Ta'ala but
the idea is is to really reflect
on one of the prophetic dot
that
is is taught to us by the
prophet mohammed salah salem whether he's taken from the Quran or the prophesy sedums life or
inspired by the prophet mohammed salah salem but to live in these under and to have
something with us as
we are making our do as we're spending time in the night with
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala were calling upon Allah were you
know pleading with Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and as we've been talking about the doha is
is such an essential and critical component of our
relationship with allah subhanaw taala in the space of worship well
a bad you know supplicating is worship and
so we want to make sure that this Ramadan we have a very healthy conversational relationship
with Allah we
spend as much time talking to Allah and I would recommend that we are making dua
before
method as you
know those last moments before the
other I know none of it whether it's you know 15 minutes or 30 minutes before
or 10 minutes before even 5 minutes depending on your schedule take
time to really carve out to call upon allah subhanaw taala anytime
between a van and hama you know and we have massaged it in our home now
so insha'Allah every
time that we have a moment
of event in a moment of calm over sitting down that is a time before du-ha
the
latter part of the night is from the most sacred times of dua and stuff it
in I've been as hard those who are seeking forgiveness in the moments of in those
early morning hours and so all of these are precious times where we can make dua
in the times of Bella in the times of hardship it is you
know a time of doing in the time of rain it is a time of dua
and etc and certainly Ramadan is a month of
da-da-da-da-da
and if any hurry ug booed our today either done if my caught my servants call
then ask about me then let them know that I'm closer I'm there I am close
and I respond to the call of the caller of he or she calls and so
we have to come to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala in a state in us in a
disposition of humility in a disposition of mascara that we are in need of him and
at this position of imploring allah subhanaw taala and begging allah and you know and and
really you
know al l ha where we ask allah in in a form that is
that
is incessant in nature that i asked a lot i ask allah i ask allah bring
your worries bring your concerns bring your fears bring your pains bring
your stress bring your aspirations bring it all to Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and spend that
quality time in sha allah who tada
I wanted to begin this
sessions with this
dua this will be the first day that we cover in
this 30 day series in
these 30 sessions and that is the dua of
of
worry and anxiety and fear and stress being lifted and I you know how I felt
that this had this dua is so relevant to our particular states right now in the
circumstances that we're going through you can find this door I think I posted it in
the above
the video so you can read the Arabic and the English the
translation as well as the transliteration
so
I'll read it in Arabic and
you can follow along and you know prepare your heart and then I'll explain it briefly
insha allah la ilaha illa allah Duke even though our Vedic even
automatic now so a TV addict Marvin fee Rahman Adlon
fear about as
a
localized mean who alec sometta be enough suck and Zelda who Viki Tabak our lambda ho
I had a mean hullick I was thought to be here l meanwhile in the entire
Quran and Alina Robby
aqua Lumina or a miracle be onerous Adri well Jenna whose knee was a heavy hand
me this
is a beautiful dua of the prophet muhammad sallallaahu said no more he says o Allah
I am your servant and I
am the son of your servant the son
of your maidservant my
forelock is in your hand ie you have total mastery over me you know this is
this is the most beautiful expression of surrender I am your servant the son of your
male servant the from some of your female servant I am your servant now
see a TB addict you know my entire forelock my entire neck is in your hand
meaning you have categorical in complete control over me and that is
from the ED above dua is the praise of allah and to
illustrate humility in in the Magnificent court of allah subhana WA Ta'ala and this is a
beautiful way to express that your
command over me is forever
executed and your decree over me is just meaning that whatever you want allah subhanaw taala
will certainly be will certainly be and
i know that i can never exist outside of your decree and none of us for
that matter can have any choices outside of the decree of allah subhanaw taala and what
you decree for me Allah is the
best it is what is most fair
because
this is from Allah and this is the disposition of the humble servant that I have
I acknowledge your decree I acknowledge that your decree is upon me all the time and
that you decree only the best of things for me and
then
the prophet sallallaahu Selim says I
ask
you by every name belonging to you which you named yourself with or revealed in your
book or you talked to any of your creation or you have preserved in the knowledge
of the unseen with you so
this is the expression of the prophesy send them to illustrate that Ya Allah I know
that you have inglis names endless descriptives and so he's asking with every possible Avenue of
potentially where names making four come from whether they are names that he has named himself
that he sent to us in Revelation that he's talked to some of his creation that
he has kept for him in the unseen realm and
all
of this build up is to ask for what I
asked
you a lot that you make the Quran the life of my heart and the
light of my breasts the light of my chest that's
what the process LM is seeking
as he experienced divine revelation in that first moment the
words of allah subhanaw taala the revealed text the holy scripture the book of healing and
clarity and increase in illumination
Allah
I ask
you to make the Quran the
life of my heart and the
light of my chest and is
this not the most appropriate way for us to begin the month of Ramadhan that we
ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala in his magnificent in endless names that
he makes the Quran the life of our of our hearts and that he illuminates our
chests because we're bringing and this is a dua that is specifically utilized for what for
the removal of worry and angst and concern and fear and hardship because
when the ad is embedded in me and the
Quran is embedded in you then
all of those other negative realities they simply become overshadowed and they they are they are
brought light is brought into the being by the Quran and
everything else is expelled and
so
we want Allah and we go to Allah with humility because Allah he gives the
the sacred keys of the Quran and this light he gives it to those who deserve
it and those who seek it and and to deserve it I have to seek it
sincerely and I have to want it and I have to believe in the power of
the Quran but
you make the Quran the life of my heart and the
light of my chest and a
departure from my sorrow and a release for
my anxiety we
ask Allah subhana WA Ta'ala to make this dua a reality in our nights of Ramadan
so
let us repeat this dua together after
understanding it after
internalizing it's Mirani after
falling in a state of humility at the doorstep of the majestic we come to Allah
in the state of masks Anna a state of of
impoverishment the state of need knowing that our realities are fully and completely and utterly in
the hands of Allah subhana WA Ta'ala and that we are categorically reliant upon him we
say a la una in
me and repeat with me in sha allah allahumma
inni
and if you need to you can read the transliteration allahumma inni
a
baduk he knew a Vedic every
new emit emetic now see a TV addict Marvin
fee hawk MOOC admin
fee kabak as a
Luka beacon this man who anak cimetidine of sack o and delta who Fickett arabic Alentejo
adam in holic i was taught to behave here L mean ye beer in Dec entity
Allah Ya
Allah and tell Adam karana Ravi
Akali be well
Newroz Audrey was
Jenna whose
knee whether had her
me alone a menial banana mean we ask allah subhanaw taala to beautify us with the
dua of the prophet muhammad salallahu alayhi wasalam may you use this do I mean we
all use this dua as we turn to Allah and we talk to Allah and we
supplicate to Allah may
Allah make us of those who always call upon him and never disconnect ourselves from him
and are always in conversation with him may these nights be alive in
the
vicar and the remembrance of Allah in sauna into
a in
Vick in
km
ensued
in the war may Allah bring life to our nights with the Quran may
the Quran be present with us accompanying us throughout our nights and throughout our days may
we never be disconnected from the Quran maybe not be amongst those who the prophet salallahu
alaihe salam lamented to allah in nepal me tejada hoddan for an Amur Allah my people
they neglected the Quran Ya Allah make us of those who
are always of the
Quran make us an
and never allow us to be amongst those who left
the Quran Allah
bring life to us through the Quran bring
life to a through Salah and through the allahumma Ameen barakallahu li walakum Ramadan
Kareem Ramadan Mubarak may
lost Rantala help us to have p.m.
lane every single night in these blessed days and may Allah grant us salvation in these
nights may he grant us and it may
he grant us that we are saved in these nights and that we are written amongst
the people of Jannah and that we exit this month with clean slates as our mother's
bird us and that we exit this month in this
month in the best of States better than what we entered into this month with categorically
and may we find our burdens lifted and our worries removed in our fears eliminated
and
may we be together with our loved ones in this life and be evening-night Allah in
the company of an Habib al mustafa sallallahu alayhi wasallam in the afterlife allahu Medina Sidonia
Hassan our fill IATI Hassan of Akina a turban our table
moti Toba rind and moti Shahada other than note e Jonathan una rima or Solander whom
allah sayidina muhammad wa our hero DeWanna and l-hamdu lillahi rabbil aalameen assalamualaikum warahmatullah